the president I'm going to try to bring
this budget debate down to earth and
talk a little bit about the reality
what's happening and go beyond a lot of
numbers that are out there my good
friend from Alabama who sits with me on
the Budget Committee makes the point
that this country has a severe budget
crisis and he is right he is right the
question is how did we get to where we
are today and how do we go forward in a
way that is fair and responsible to
address this crisis and in that regard
the senator from Alabama and I have some
very strong disagreements how do we get
to where we were where we are today when
not so many years ago the day that
george w bush became president we had a
significant surplus we had a surplus
when clinton left office now we have a
major deficit crisis whether a number of
reasons number one against my vote we
are fighting a war in iraq which by the
time we take care of our last veteran is
going to cost us um three trillion
dollars war in iraq i didn't hear any of
my Republican friends saying we can't go
to war unless we figure out a way to pay
for that number to my Republican friends
for years have been pushing huge tax
breaks for the very very wealthiest
people in this country I didn't hear
them ask how that was going to be paid
for number three on the President Bush
was strong Republican support against my
vote Congress passed a 400 billion
dollar plus Medicare Part D prescription
drug program written by the insurance
companies and the drug companies drove
up the deficit number four against my
boat Congress voted for a massive
bailout of wall
Street didn't hear too many people
talking about how could we pay for that
seven hundred billion dollars to bail
out Wall Street didn't hear them arguing
that it was too much money would drive
up the deficit now the Republicans
yesterday mr. president brought forth
and voted on HR 1 and almost all of them
voted for it and those that didn't
actually want it to go further now the
main point that I want to make this
morning is a we do have to address the
deficit crisis but B we have to address
it in a way that is fair and is
responsible and not solely on the backs
of working families the middle class the
elderly the sick and the poor that is
immoral that is wrong and that is bad
economics to my mind it is absolutely
absurd that when my Republican friends
talk about deficit reduction they forget
to talk about the reality that the
wealthiest people in this country today
have never had it so good that the
effect of the real tax rate for the
richest people in this country is the
lowest on record and that the wealthiest
people in this country the top 2% have
received many many hundreds of billions
of dollars in tax breaks so I ask my
Republican friends why do you want to
balance the budget on the backs of
low-income children low-income senior
citizens those that are sick those that
are vulnerable without asking the
wealthiest people in this country who
have never had it so good to put one
penny one penny into deficit reduction I
think that is wrong and the American
people think that is wrong when we talk
about deficit reduction we have got to
talk about shared sacrifice everybody
playing the role not just little kids
not just the elderly nacho
the sick but even there I say it people
who have a whole lot of money and who
have never done so well mr. president I
have not been impressed at how the media
has been covering this issue because I
think they have not made it clear to the
American people how devastating the cut
saw that the Republicans want to impose
on working families let me just very
briefly tick some of them all the
Republicans want to throw over 200,000
children off of the head start program
every working family in America knows
how hot it is today to come up with
affordable childcare early childhood
education we have the highest rate of
childhood poverty in the industrialized
world Republican solution is / head
start by twenty percent cut 218,000 kids
off a head start and lay off 55 heads
55,000 head start instructor instructors
mr. president you well know that the
cost of a college education today is so
high that many young people are giving
up their dream of going to college while
many others are graduating deeply in
debt Republican solution / Pell grants
by five point seven billion dollars and
reducing reduce or eliminate Pell grants
for m4 9.4 million low-income college
students middle-class families working
class families you hear that we're going
to balance the budget by either
eliminating or lowering Pell grants the
ability of young people to go to college
for over 9 million college students now
I know in my office we get calls every
week from senior citizens people with
disabilities widows were having a hard
time getting a timely response toward
their social security claim takes too
long to process the paperwork what the
Republicans want to do is slice
ish the Social Security Administration
the people who administer the Social
Security for seniors with a disabled for
widows and orphans by one point seven
billion dollars and that means I half a
million Americans who are legally
entitled to Social Security benefits
will have to wait significantly longer
times in order to receive them mr.
president we have 50 million Americans
who have no health insurance today 45
thousand Americans died because they
don't get to a doctor on time last year
is a lot of health care reform I work
very hard with a member many members of
the Senate to expand community health
centers so that more and more low and
moderate income people could walk into a
doctor's office get health care dental
care low-cost prescription drugs mental
health counseling Republicans want a
slash in HR 1 the bill they voted for
yesterday they want to deny primary
health care to 11 million Americans at a
time when state after state is cutting
back on Medicaid what are you supposed
to do if you're 50 years old you have a
pain in your chest you don't have any
health insurance where do you go and
Republicans want to deny health care to
another 11 million Americans it's the
president for the poorest people in this
country community services Block Grants
provide the infrastructure the ability
to get out emergency food help emergency
help to pay the electric bill LIHEAP
they are the infrastructure in this
country that protects the poorest and
most vulnerable people Republicans want
to slash 405 million dollars from the
community services Block Grant that is
wrong and the president's proposed cut
to the community service Block Grant is
also wrong we have in real terms sixteen
percent of our population today a
workforce is really unemployed if you
add together the official unemployment
those people have given up looking for
work those people are working part-time
want to work full-time Republicans want
to / 2 billion dollars in federal job
training program
Republicans want to slash 400 million in
lie he in life that is the program that
in my state and all over this country
enables people to stay warm in the
wintertime we have a lot of senior
citizens in the state of Vermont getting
by on thirteen fourteen thousand dollars
a year income they need help it gets
cold in Vermont gets 20 below zero you
got to stay warm people don't have the
income LIHEAP has been a very valuable
tool Republicans want to slash four
hundred million dollars for like they
want to slash the EPA Environmental
Protection Agency by thirty percent
these are the people who have
successfully enforce the Clean Air Act
the Clean Water Act so that the air we
breathe doesn't give us asthma doesn't
provide us with the suit which makes us
sick Clean Air Act has been an enormous
success in cleaning up our air
Republicans want to slash that by thirty
percent Republicans want to cut the
women and infant nutrition programs this
is the program that provides the WIC
program that provides supplemental
nutrition program for women infants and
children they want to cut that by 750
million dollars poverty in America is
increasing what we understand is a
pregnant women and little kids do not
get good nutrition the likelihood is
that they're going to get that the
births might be low weight or the little
babies might come down with illnesses if
they don't have good nutrition poverty
is increasing and yet the Republicans
want to cut the WIC program by 750
million dollars 10% title one education
funding everybody understands we have
problems with education right now launch
dropout rates Republicans want to want
to cut five billion dollars from the
Department of Education on and on and on
it goes now what do I think do I think
that it is appropriate that we balance
the budget on preg
pregnant women and infants who need
nutrition well I think you should throw
two hundred thousand kids off the head
start program but I think you cut the
Social Security Administration severely
do I think you cut Planned Parenthood
which is done such a good job in
preventing unwanted pregnancies does
that make sense I don't think so I don't
think that is good for America but I do
believe we have to move toward a
balanced budget so what is one way to go
forward other than savage cuts on
programs for the most vulnerable people
in this country and that is I think we
have got to begin talking about revving
you not just cuts mr. president today I
will be introducing legislation which
does two things number one it creates a
millionaire surtax which will be used
strictly for deficit reduction it will
be a five point four percent surtax on
income over 1 million dollars that says
that all income all households that have
income of over a million dollars will
pay a five point four percent sure tax
on that income which will go into a
emergency deficit reduction fund just
doing that asking millionaires to pay a
little bit more in taxes after all of
the huge tax breaks they have received
will bring in approximately 50 billion
dollars a year now mr. president I think
that that is a good idea but it is not
just me who thinks it is a good idea
recently last week there was an NBC
news/wall Street Journal poll and they
ask the American people what is the best
way to go forward on Deficit Reduction
eighty-one percent of the american
people believe it is totally acceptable
or mostly acceptable to impose a surtax
on millionaires to reduce the deficit
the American people get it they
understand you can't move toward deficit
reduction just by cutting programs that
working families the middle class
low-income people desperately need in
order to survive
the midst of this terrible recession
they understand that serious responsible
deficit reduction requires shared
sacrifice it is insane and I use that
word advisable advisable it is insane to
be talking about deficit reduction as my
Republican friends do on one hand and
then say oh yes we have got to give
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars in tax breaks to the top 1% the
top 2% when those guys are doing
phenomenally well are seeing an
effective tax rate lower than it has
been in decades and have received huge
tax breaks already why does anyone think
it is moral or right to move toward
deficit reduction on the backs of the
week and the vulnerable I understand and
I know something about politics I do
understand that the parents of kids who
aren't headstock do not make large
campaign contributions and I know that
the senior citizens of this country who
need some help with Social Security do
not make large campaign contributions I
understand that I understand the college
students desperately trying to go
through college on a Pell Grant do not
make large campaign contributions but
there is a sense of morality here that
we have to deal with and I think that it
makes no sense I think it is immoral I
think it is bad economics to balance the
budget on the backs of working families
while we give continued tax breaks to
those people who don't need it so mr.
president today we will be introducing a
piece of legislation which I hope will
have strong support I think it paves the
way for us to go forward in serious
deficit reduction in a way that is fair
do we need to make cuts absolutely
absolutely but do we also need to ask
the wealthiest people in this country to
start contributing to a deficit
reduction I think that we do so once
again the legislation that I've
introduced today creates a millionaire
surtax of five point four percent which
would bring it about 50
billion dollars a year to be used
exclusively for an emergency deficit
reduction fund and we also end tax
breaks for big oil and gas companies
which are bringing at about three and a
half billion a year over the past decade
the five largest oil companies in the
United States have earned nearly a
trillion dollars in profits meanwhile in
recent years some of the very largest
oil companies in America and paid
absolutely nothing in federal income
taxes the fact some of them have
actually gotten a refund rebate from the
IRS so that is why plea my plea is that
yes the need for deficit reduction is
real it is urgent let's go forward but
let's go forward in a way that is fair
and responsible and not simply on the
backs of the most vulnerable people in
this country oh and with that